the pandemic's many impacts are still
drilling down
delay and disruption here here
and even here are all now hitting
consumers hard
here in fact fuel prices are now the
highest they've been
in eight years petrol on average one
pound 35 per liter and diesel even more
supply chain disruption is key to the
problem
but so is a classic supply and demand
imbalance
whereas uh some months ago we had
bulging brimming stocks of oil with not
you know nothing to do with it those
countries have been restraining their
production which causes
the oil stops to spare oil to
gradually dwindle away and at the same
time we've now got
a big economic recovery underway
expensive fuel is bad news for consumers
but could it be good news for the
climate
the government wants us to all drive
electric could this
accelerate the switch gina moved to an
electric car recently
saving money she says was just part of
the reason
i drive a load and you know i've got two
kits some
you know driving that much is very
expensive and that was one of the
reasons i decided to go electric i
wanted to go electric for a very long
time
but the other thing is the environment i
just i've you know i'm i like
sustainable
things and i think that that was the
best way to go
but for many like sally who's also
considering it
there's a big immediate barrier
huge purchase price again that's
something that we're really kind of
not not put off by but also the idea
that um
you know in a few years time that
actually those those hybrids and the
electric cars are going to be updated so
quickly
um that is it worth buying it now
because we we may end up
you know having this vehicle that's
actually quite dated very very quickly
electric cars are ultimately cheaper to
run
experts say high fuel costs could offer
a unique opportunity to incentivize
and the government should seize it
perhaps there is an opportunity now to
really capitalize on the
the lower rates that ev drivers can you
know can enjoy
and get more people into those but the
answer really is around
kind of flooding the market with new
electric vehicles
we know at the rac that most drivers
still buy their cars
second or third hand so the only way
those drivers are going to be able to
afford electric ones
is if there's enough supply at the top
at a time when energy prices are also
rising for many the cost of going green
is still
prohibitive for consumers at the pump
the pandemic's many ramifications still
ratcheting up
helen and smith sky news